name is Nina discesa and I am the
chairman of McCann erickson's new york
office and the new york office is what
we like to say the flagship office of
mccann-erickson global network
a mastercard is actually a pretty good
in case history because when leap it was
a new business pitch there were six
agencies who were going after this
business and we were all given the same
brief all we were we were told to use
their existing end line which is kind of
what I guess you would call slogan which
is was it that the future of money and
it was all over the world everywhere you
went you saw a MasterCard the future of
money nobody remembered it but it was
all over the world and so all six
agencies tried to execute against that
positioning line and we were the only
ones that did not do that because we we
couldn't we couldn't get any resonance
with the consumer with that line it was
pushing us in the direction of the
futuristic non you know electronic money
it wasn't really a very warm and
friendly place to be and so one day one
creative person came up with a line
there are some things money can't buy
for everything else there's MasterCard
and another creative person came up with
the priceless campaign
how effective advertising is advertising
that changes the behavior of the
consumer for one thing and also
effective advertising is advertising
that makes people feel a certain way
about a brand mean it's all about the
brand and how people allow that brand to
influence their lives does it help them
feel a certain way about the product or
the brand that you're trying to
advertise the content is so consumer
driven it's kind of interesting about
you know how you maintain the
stewardship of a brand when somebody
everybody's doing so much of their own
kind of advertising
I remember many years ago like 10 or 15
years ago there was an idea and to put
advertising on the on the on the runways
where the baggage was being the baggage
runways and airports so that while you
were standing there are wondering if
your baggage was actually going to come
through the door you could be looking at
advertising on the on the rubber on the
rubber strips and I don't know if that
was ever done I certainly don't remember
seeing it in the travels I've done but
you have to be careful when you surround
the consumer with advertising messaging
that you don't irritate them in the
process and that means that you have to
be entertaining you have to be appealing
you have to make them want to watch what
you're saying so a lot of the
user-generated advertising might be
interesting now and I think it's fun to
think about it I think it's still an art
form advertising and the creative end of
advertising still needs our artists and
craftsmen and people who are good at
storytelling and creating imagery and
making things beautiful and interesting
to watch so I don't know that the
user-generated commercials are going to
take over there is kind of interesting
now I like them I think it's fun but
there's always it's like a mosaic you
know there's a place for everything
I think that the return on the
investment is something that the clients
are that's the thing they're most
concerned about obviously good they're
spending a lot of money to advertise to
the right audiences the packaged goods
clients the clients that have a
universal messages and that are mass
marketed and appeal to mass audiences
they have a pretty effective way of
measuring the effectiveness of their
commercials the big question there is
does the do we start creating
commercials that will test well and not
commercials that are bright and clever
and will engage the consumer and the
really good creative people are the ones
who can divorce it's very hard to test a
branding commercial commercials that are
not selling a specific service or
product that are just trying to enhance
a brand because there's no way what we
do have ways of measuring a brand's
success you know we there's tons and
tons of marketing companies that do
these tracking studies so that we know
where they're a brand where a brand lies
in the minds of the consumer so there's
always ways of measuring things and the
clients who are spending so much money
on their messaging are not going to
spend money if they are not relatively
sure that the messaging they are using
is effective and is reaching their goal
so I don't know how anybody could think
that advertising is not measurable the
bane of our existence as creative people
is that it's constantly being measured
and and we're rewarded based on our
ability to reach these consumers and
motivate them and change their behavior
and make the brand their brand and make
the products their products so that's
what the business is about that's what
the whole business is about is measuring
the effectiveness of our ideas